fire up your super nintendo and bust out
your old move list
how do i how do i do luke hanks fireball
again right right be
right down ah screw it low kick low kick
low kick that the only move you know my
hbo max's mortal kombat movie has a ride
from the out world and it's here for
your soul
i'll swallow your soul come get some
and in this video we're going to be
looking into just what the heck is going
on in this mortal kombat reboot while we
never even saw a mortal kombat
tournament actually take place
and what this movie could be setting up
for a sequel including the introduction
of some new
characters but before we begin make sure
to like and subscribe to the channel
get over here or else be forced into a
staring contest with kano i also give
really good foot massages
now before we can really understand why
the smoke monster from lost and his
ragtag group of cronies is here on earth
we have to dive into everyone's favorite
topic
mortal kombat lore now there's like a
bajillion mortal kombat games worth of
storylines and lore put out there over
the years involving
multiple timelines resetting those
timelines and then resetting them again
but all you really need to know is that
in the mortal kombat universe there are
multiple realms with earth realm being
the home of our heroes
and outworld being the home of shang
soon and his boss the conquering emperor
xiao khan
who we don't actually get to see apart
from in statues there are more realms
one in particular that we'll get to
later but for now
know that the realms are basically
controlled by beings called the elder
gods
and in order to prevent outworld from
becoming too powerful they've set up an
interdimensional fight club called
mortal kombat and this fight club has a
few rules
first rule of fight club is you do not
talk about my club
second rule of fight club is you do not
talk about fight club actually rule two
is if you want to invade another realm
and take it over you have to win
10 mortal combats in a row and at the
point of the movie's beginning
eltworld has won 9 out of their needed
10. but unlike the original mortal
kombat movie from 1995 which by the way
you should check out my video detailing
some of the key differences from that
film and this one
this mortal kombat never actually
conducts that 10th tournament
rather shang soon is looking to cheat
his way to victory by eliminating all
the earthrealm champions
before the tournament even begins thus
giving elworld an easy w
and shang soon and shao khan free reign
to invade and
claim the realm now why cheat
considering shang soon
already claimed nine victories in a row
well there just so happens to be a
prophecy in place claiming that now
a new group of champions will quote rise
from the blood of hanzo hasashi
and basically set eltworld's win streak
all the way back to zero
so shang soon who has the power to
travel between realms without being
noticed by the elder gods
breaks the rules of fight club and sends
out his thugs like reptile
aka seizoth to track down and kill
anyone with this dragon mark the mark
that means you've been chosen as one of
earthrealm's champions for mortal combat
trying to foil this plan is earth
realm's protector the thunder god raiden
basically he's a god but not quite an
elder god he protects earth but he can't
directly meddle in the rules of mortal
combat
he can however give the earth realm
champions a little push in the right
direction
and help the champions unlock their
arcana a gift given by the dragon mark
that grants you superhuman powers
like shooting fireballs out of your
hands in x-men cyclops beam or even like
a really sharp hat
remarkable unfortunately you don't just
get your superpowers right off the bat
you can only unlock your arcana through
training and basically some sort of deep
emotional moment or
understanding about yourself after
sub-zero turns jax's arms into popsicles
and breaks them off for a snack
jax gains his arcana and new shiny metal
arms when desperately trying to save
sonia from fallen debris
cole gains his arcana trying to save his
family from prince goro
and kano gains his when he realizes he's
an angry a-hole i also give really good
foot massages
and this is where our main protagonist
cole comes into play
as he's the only person in the crew to
have had his mark of the dragon since
birth everyone else had to have the mark
transfer over to them
after killing another person who already
had one like what happens to sonia after
she jams the travelocity gnome right
into kano's brain oh how does that feel
travelocity you'll never roam alone and
cole has had his mark from birth for a
very specific reason he's the descendant
of hanzo hasashi
a famous warrior of the shireyo who bore
the dragon mark and was killed
along with his family at the hands of
bihan there's a whole other backstory
between these two but basically each one
is a member of a feuding clan
behind from the lin kuei
hanzo from the shire
once dead hanzo is taken to the nether
realm another one of the many realms in
this universe
that's basically well hell and it's
there he becomes scorpion
bihan on the other hand ends up in the
out world and becomes sub-zero
fortunately though sub-zero fails in
eliminating hanzo's bloodline as his
daughter was hidden away under the
floorboards and later picked up by
raiden
the hisashi bloodline lives on and it's
only when raiden gives cole hanzo's
kunai that the prophecy can be fulfilled
as just like what was foretold from the
blood of hanzo literally
cole's blood scorpion is brought back to
earth realm to help defeat sub-zero
the last of shang tsung's cronies thus
foiling outworld's attempt at undoing
the prophecy
but though shang tsun has been stopped
today he has a final warning for raiden
and the earth realm
champions no matter how many of my
people you put in the ground
there will always be another to take
their place
death is only another portal aka i'll be
back in the sequel losers
and speaking of the sequel a lot has
been set up for a potential
mortal kombat 2 as at the end of the
movie raiden has tasked cole and the
gang with finding more
champions remember that at this point
the 10th mortal combat has still yet to
take place
and there is one more opportunity for
outworld to win and invade the earth
realm
which begs the question who might we see
fighting in the next mortal combat
of course teased at the end of the movie
is none other than johnny cage as cool
sets out for hollywood to recruit the
action superstar
a man whose original movie motivation
was basically to prove that he's not
just an actor
he can really fight you win the
tournament you win their respect
[Music]
now while that's one character the movie
blatantly foreshadows as being a part of
the sequel
there are some more subtle hints as to
other characters we might see
primarily noob saibat now if you're a
fan of the mortal kombat series you'll
know that noob saibot is the
resurrection of the dead bihan
sort of like how hanzo hasashi is sent
to the nether realm and comes back as
scorpion
bihan aka subzero 1 is reborn in the
nether realm as the evil incarnate
wraith noob sebat
and if noob sebat makes an appearance
that could also mean the introduction of
two
other characters one being sub-zero part
two as when bihan dies the mantle of
sub-zero is taken over by his brother
koi liang
the other being quan qi a demon of the
nether realm who resurrected scorpion
and immortal combat lore is the one who
resurrects bihan into noob saibat
now last but not least we could be
seeing kano again who throughout the
film is
notably missing his trademark metal
plate eyepiece
i couldn't help but notice that when
sonia offs him with a guard gnome she
shoves it directly into his right
eye the same location of his typical
metal plate
it could mean he'll be coming back with
his trademark look to fill the void
it'll be interesting to see how they set
up the sequel especially if there's
going to be an
actual mortal kombat tournament and what
other fighters from the franchise will
be brought in
hopefully they'll also bring in more
references from the games like they did
with liu kang's dragon fatality on cabal
and scorpion's fire breath fatality on
sub-zero
just to name a few or even more
recognizable fight stages like they did
with the pit
and pit 2. and i know they had to show
jax's fatality here but i kind of wish
he had uppercut him off the map
that was always so satisfying in the
games
[Music]
flawless victory so thanks for watching
everyone and please remember to like
subscribe and share to help the channel
out and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you